[Music]
college students tend to get stressed
out by finals but if you attend the
University of Utah you have an option
it's called the cry closet the closet is
a creation of an art student called Nemo
Miller and it exists for stressed-out
students who can step into it for up to
ten minutes of crying to help cope with
the tests the closet interior includes
fuzzy stuffed animals for maximum coping
question is is it time to go national
with this weeping wardrobes erected
across this fragile country only one
woman can make the case for that and she
is of course Cathy Arun the founding
publisher of Catalina magazine and our
liberal Sherpa Kathy it's great to see
you tonight hey good to see you so at
first glance it seems so confusing
because College of course is the least
stressful place there is I mean it's
already a yoga rich well sure I mean you
go to class for two hours a week and get
drunk the rest of the time oh come on
why are college students parents no it's
very stressful they're they're learning
they're the the future these are our
citizens of tomorrow and they're
learning as much as I can
there's stress this can be so they need
psychological health they need this
bioenergetic way to get out their stress
they need ten minutes of a good cry and
a cry closet to then be prepared to take
those exams from everything they've
learned in those classes we don't have
time for you to define bioenergetic on
the show some of the let that pass I'll
tell you later thank you
but do you does this suggest something
maybe about the fragility of their
mental health I mean if you're so
stressed about taking some some dumb
test at some dumb school doesn't that
mean that you're kind of on the edge of
a breakdown well no don't we all need a
good old-fashioned cry this is all it's
saying this is an old-fashioned remedy
to a modern-day problem it's it's just
about crying ten minutes of crying
everyone needs a stress ball many people
own stress balls so this is just an
interpretation of a giant stress ball so
let's say we had a war let's say I don't
know pick a country China challenge just
in some way where we had to mobilize a
large number of Americans to defend the
homeland okay but everyone's crying
would anybody be left to fight the war I
mean can you really defend a country if
you're encouraging kids to
about final exams well this is about
psychological health so if everyone
takes a moment aside to just Center
themselves ground themselves have a cry
maybe four to three minutes and then go
fight that war I'm sure the war would be
won with people in such a great state of
mind could you take a break
conceivably between battles to cry well
I think the break would probably have to
be done before the battle but it would
be the right mindset before that battle
that they would win that battle so I
think that's what this whole closet is
about the cry Clause it's about getting
that right state of mind
so yeah would you want to use a closet
others have cried in a problem with it
sounds very cozy and Google has done
this out in Silicon Valley so many
companies have created these these you
know ping pong tables and very
comfortable corporate settings where
people can let off steam so if a cry
closet is called for how about like a
petting zoo like a bunny stroking
station was that is that too far could
you envision that you know it's it's the
future if people are comfortable and
work better after being centered and
calmer then why not bring the bunnies in
yes let me just let me ask you a macro
point and I haven't talked to this out
of what I don't want to shock you
anything but like I thought the whole
idea was to get people to come out of
the closet but here you're looking right
in the camera and saying people go back
in the closet do you as a progressive
feel good about that go in for 10
minutes and get that cry so that you can
come out confidently and feel good I
mean you might want to go into that cry
closet right before show and you know
have a great show afterwards I mean I
know this is just like television you
want to be too honest but let's try to
push the limits with you if you knew a
man who you thought I could date that
man or marry that man I find that man
attractive and he said I'm sorry I just
got to taking a quick break and go cry
in a closet while squeezing a stuffed
animal that would kind of wreck the deal
for you wouldn't it honestly I think you
would probably say I'm gonna go center
myself so that I can be a stronger
better person for you yeah I would love
that person I think that's great I think
that's healthy who doesn't want to be
with them no part of you would part of
you would look on in contemptuously and
say you weepy little freak stop crying
right I would say what a strong person
who understands
themselves or here self or whatever
pronoun that person wishes to call
believe you I don't believe you for a
second yeah I think you'd want to think
that just as a as a good progressive you
would think this is wholesome this is
consist of minor ideology no but on a
gut level you would say stop whimpering
every place as a cry closet every place
as a safe place I mean cry closets can
be the bathroom right now at many
companies
everyone needs a good cry closet it's an
old-fashioned way of letting out stress
and relieving tension yeah I'm gonna
leave it there okay Kathy aru the
liberal liberal Sherpa great to see you
thank you good to see you